dans pourquoi on dit je vous raconte ce
qui se cache derrière les expressions de
la langue française alors abonnez vous
et n'oubliez pas que je suis cloche
salue les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux savez vous pourquoi on dit avoir
du bol
[Musique]
s'agit vous le savez d'une expression
signifiant avoir de la chance elle est
apparue au 20e siècle
mais dans cette histoire le bol n'a rien
à voir avec celui dans lequel on prend
notre petit déjeuner ce mot est bien ici
de l'anglais ball et désigne un
récipient plus profond que large dont le
retrouve aussi en néerlandais et en
allemand sous des formes assez similaire
dans toutes ces langues
les racines européennes du mot signifie
enflé est rempli le mot ball a ainsi
pris avec le temps un autre sens en
argot il désigne la partie renflée bien
connu de notre anatomie humaine le cul
voilà c'est dit avoir du bol est donc
une autre façon de dire havre 1-2 qu
autrement dit avoir de la chance
la première rares gothique que soient
ses origines est devenu aujourd'hui plus
polie que la seconde pour parler de la
bonne fortune
avec un peu de chance ou de bol je
suppose que vous avez déjà deviné que
dans l'expression en avoir ras-le-bol le
bol du petit déjeuner n'a rien à voir
non plus si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]